It feels great...
...especially after babies, so, you know, to be back here and to be shooting with Max once again.
He's a total ham!
He started right away. Just super, super comfortable.
Of course, eventually, nap time kicks in and tiredness like we all do...
...but, you know, it was great. It was just super, super great and...
...he's just, he's a trooper.
Beauty to me, that's a tough question to answer.
It's an exuberance of your inner self,...
...honestly. Not to be cliche, but it really boils down to that.
Once, I think, you have a child, you just have a different appreciation for joy and tap in life.
It allows you to experience a whole new side of yourself that you were never really able to before.
I have at least and it's an amazing thing,...
...and it keeps getting better every year and every day to be honest.